when you talk about the nuclear arsenal
it seems like a virus like a computer
virus
an idea virus was infected in some
people
and is now demoralizing and crippling
our ability to function as a nation
because you've got people who how are we
supposed to have a national defense if
america is inherently racist and white
people this that and that
but the other thing i think is uh well
i i i don't want to go as to far as far
as to say that there that this was
intentionally done
but the the general idea i'm bringing up
is if this is reaching
so many different facets of our of our
country you have
the partisan divide between look a lot
of people have said it's it's
the culture wars libertarian versus
authoritain authoritarian nationalist
versus globalist
it could be woke versus anti-woke i
don't know but i'll tell you this
if you have people who believe in an
ideology with no real structure it's
just a chaotic
amorphous destructive force and it's
growing because people are scared to
speak up against it
then it is spreading through to into our
industries and eventually will just
erode it like some kind of mold tearing
away at the foundation you know what i
mean
i totally know what you mean and it's
interesting to see it in in corporations
right
i mean you know you're you're kind of
classical marxists
uh if you told them hey your ideology
that has been adapted over the
generations and kind of
transposed onto kind of modern
conceptions of race
will now be in the boardrooms of the
major
kind of technological and and industrial
corporations of the world
they'd look at you like you were
completely insane but the thing is that
i've talked to
executives off the record um you know
anonymously rather
or say hey you know what's going on why
is big tech
companies why are they just like all in
on this stuff and they said
because you can't say no 98 of people in
my workforce
don't care they don't want to deal with
it it's like nerdy engineers
and then business guys they don't want
anything to do with this stuff they're
apolitical kind of at best
but if you have even three or four
people that are kind of committed
ideologues that want to bring in and say
we need a diversity program sounds good
diversity is good
you know fantastic and then
and then they get kind of a foothold and
then you can't say no
you don't want to be the executive set
saying oh we're not going to have a
diversity program red bull did
um red bull did but red bull is a kind
of different company
you know and and red bull can operate in
a different ownership structure
a different political culture and the
fact is a lot of our kind of
most high-growth companies in the united
states are now
physically rooted in prestige very
progressive
cities and this is a defensive maneuver
they're trying to buy i mean
you know uh in in seattle now the new
hockey arena sponsored by
uh bezos is now the climate change arena
i mean like you know so they're it's
almost kind of like a
a trying to buy some kind of piece and
you know what's not going to work you
don't i think is happening with this
critical race theory stuff
uh at least as it pertains to this kind
of general
wokeness that you know people like the
progressives use
it's it's not really in my opinion
there's not really any real core
ideology behind it
there's just like kind of
bits and pieces and fragments that are
duct taped together to give them
something they can claim is an ideology
and the reason i say this is
you can see them contradict themselves
change definitions
and every other day it's like oh well
what i said the other day you don't
understand because you're racist or
you're wrong
they change everything over and over
again and what i see what they're
actually doing is
you have individuals who are simply
asserting their power and demanding it
and they won't back down so it's almost
like
you know you know a pecking order works
with chickens you put all the chick all
the hens in the space and then they like
figure out which one's in charge
they did an experiment where they
decided to take what they called super
chickens
these were the the hens that like were
the dominant of the pack they took all
the super chickens from different packs
put them together guess what happened
they all packed each other to death they
didn't give up
the reason why i'm telling you this when
i see people who are like posting things
on facebook and they're saying all this
woke stuff
and they're white what i do is
to try to uh communicate with them is a
basic general communication technique
where i will find something we agree on
racism is bad and then i will take their
ideology and use it
and demand that they submit to their own
ideas they will not do it
showing that their only real intention
is to be
the the super chicken pecking everyone
down so an example of this would be
a white person i just saw this exchange
on facebook a white person said
in a post if you are friends with a
black person but you don't know their
pain then you're not really friends with
that black person
and a mixed race black person responded
with
excuse me i don't need a white person
telling me about my life and my
experiences i
certainly don't need them fighting on
behalf i dealt with enough racism from
both sides
and then this person started arguing
with them you don't understand anything
you're talking about
clearly showing they don't really
believe in an ideology
so i've engaged in conversations like
this where i'll say you know things like
this is really great thank you for
fighting against racism we all agree
it's bad it's so important
now as i am the underprivileged in this
conversation
i would i would appreciate what would
would really be helpful in mending these
things
if you would agree to do this no f you
you're racist i'm in charge
i would disagree with you on two points
one is i think it is a very
rigorously and refined and structured
ideology
that is coherent um and and has been
well articulated for a long time
and we can go over the kind of lineage
of it but just to just to mention
i'm referring to the general street walk
i mean the general street people on
anything man you'd be like
you know so many people are there you
could ask yeah what i mean specifically
is
not the robin d'angelos who are writing
a book putting these things out
the regular people who are these
activists who think they're they're
pushing this ideology are actually just
trying to demand you bow to them dude i
had this experience where i was trying
to convince 2016 i was trying to tell my
friend i was in l.a telling about
hillary clinton's emails and i was like
dude
look at the he really loved hillary
she's it's her time me and it's her time
and i'm like dude
look at what she had with cindy
blumenthal i was like laying it out for
him and he was just building and getting
angry and angry and then all of a sudden
he
started screaming at me it's just your
white privilege ian
you've got white privilege and he'd
never we've been friends for like a
decade he'd never mentioned anything
like that that was somewhere deep inside
of him and he was screaming and i didn't
know what to say i was like i'm not
racist
no no it was an attempt to just i win
i'm in charge yeah it was that's weird
uh irrational
uh power play it's a power play yeah so
second
but that's actually but that is actually
and this is a really important point to
understand that is actually something
that is very much in line with their
ideology it's actually an expression of
their ideology
the critical race theorists in the
foundational texts of the 1990s
explicitly reject objectivity so it's
actually not a contradiction of their
ideology to say well you know
that's that this is this um who knows
it's not objective but
my personal narrative no no no my lived
experience my lived experience right
they love adding unnecessary adjectives
that sound smart experience oh
my lived experience what happened to my
experience right you know right
but um no but it really is and and
because they argue
and and much like marx argued is that
you know we have created these systems
like democracy like the constitution
like private property like
liberalism like civil rights even but
those are simply
camouflaged for naked power and
domination
and we have to dismiss those kind of
false structures of freedom and equality
and boil the world down to simple power
relations so whatever you do
expressing your power calling you a
white privileged
guy or or or or shutting your your
friend down even if he's
mixed race on facebook or whatever it is
is
justified ideologically because they've
rejected
objective truths they've rejected kind
of what they would call traditional
theory they
rejected norms and and then in a world
where there's nothing but power
everything is justified i yes i think
you i think if you look at everything
they've written they've created
i guess what people refer to as a kafka
trap no matter no matter what you do
you're it you know if you reject that
you're racist it proves you're racist
yeah
but it it really does feel like
none of what they're saying actually
makes sense like when they call
ben shapiro an orthodox jew a nazi and
when they call candace owens a black
woman a white supremacist
any regular person sitting down i should
imagine there's like some guy
he's sitting in a chair having a coffee
with his eyes half clothes just not
really caring about the world and you
know he's got his phone and he's looking
and then he sees across the street
candace owens a black woman and some
white guy goes you're a white
supremacist
and that guy thinks what duff that's the
weirdest thing i've ever seen
yeah like this person is deranged did
you see did you see this is really funny
video
i shouldn't call it funny but it's a
there's a black guy holding a trump flag
and a white guy wearing a black lives
matter shirt yelling at him and it's
like
yeah amazing but but it doesn't matter
because it's it
psychologically it doesn't matter
because even if it's totally absurd to
the general public
you live in a world where you have a
limited number of social connections
maybe 200
social connections like on average a
person
so if the people that are actually
meaningful to you or even weirder
the people who are in your you know
twitter mentions if you're not kind of
steeled to it at this point you're
steeled to it you can
you don't care what people say but most
people for them if you get
mobbed on twitter the first time it
happened to me it was terrifying right
i'll admit it it's terrible and you feel
like oh my god you feel like your life
is over you feel like
you know it's it's a really it's an
ephemeral thing but psychologically you
feel like it's the end of the world and
that's why it's effective
it's very effective even if it's totally
logically absurd are you familiar with
the meme
where there's like two women and they
see something and they go like oh
like this really nasty face and the guy
behind him starts going like that yeah
yeah that's how i feel about like
twitter and stuff
like explain who's the woman who's the
guy regular people are the women who
like see
all the tweets okay and go like oh
what's happening and i'm the guy who's
like everyone's tweeting at me and i'm
like
yeah all right totally you know what man
you have to get there
yeah you have to get there i've been on
the internet yeah you know
and i think there are there are people
who are trolls on the internet
who've never cared in fact they revel in
the attention yeah when people are
coming after them
but this is this is what you are correct
and how it works
but what people don't realize is that
one person can do it with sock puppet
accounts
so you're you're familiar with stock
yeah let's say you're a bakery
and you made a american flag cupcakes
for the fourth of july
and then all of a sudden on twitter you
50 notifications your phone's going
and you're like this has never happened
to you before you don't get this and you
look and they're like i can't believe
you would do this indigenous people
you are offended i can't believe it
there are migrants in this country
that's
that flag is a symbol of hatred and then
you're like well i'm getting edited by
all these people
yeah to you seeing an endless feed of
all these people saying f you you racist
feels like
everyone yeah but it is but a handful of
people it's like one
so sad lonely guy did you see that video
like the guy with all the cell phones
he's got like 60 of them and he's like
yeah well no the the the the click
farmers yeah
they'll have a wall of phones and they
walk up and they go swipe enter swipe
enter swipe ender
it reminds me of this uh the family i
think it was family guy
they uh peter griffin he's like doing
his public access show it's really
offensive
and then the f the fcc is like we've
received seven phone calls and of course
that translates to 700 billion people
like something like that like they just
extrapolate
regular people see a small handful and
it feels like everyone
and they bend immediately yeah even
having one of my goodness and you can't
blame them i mean you really have to
feel sympathy or something
he's like i'm sorry i'm a pizza owner i
don't know what's happening
it's very frightening obviously i hope
that they don't
and i think that over time as a culture
we're kind of adapting to this so it's
becoming more diffuse but
you know i'd i you have to understand it
at least there's two ways we can go with
it
yeah the the locusts gain control and
everyone just
is terrified and living underneath the
boot worried that they'll say something
wrong
and so they just they don't realize that
everyone feels the same way as they do
that would be a scary reality where i
would like this to go
is that people become calloused and then
they start saying
go f yourself yeah someone walks in
their store and says i couldn't help but
notice
that you have a poster in your window oh
yeah you want me to put up two of them
so basically we need to like adopt the
queen's mindset across the united states
you know
just don't care and i i think you're
right but i think there's another
dynamic that's really important to
establish i think
it's that in a in a kind of culture
war let's say that's the metaphor
obviously it's not a real war
um but you need to have kind of arms
parity
so you you need to have kind of uh an
equivalent
kind of destructive power on both sides
so that there's some kind of negotiated
truce
to recreate a kind of middle because
right now you're wasting your time
anyone if you're arguing with your
friend on facebook about politics and
they're at that point
there's actually not a point of dialogue
that's possible that's gone you're
wasting your time they're wasting their
time
you have to understand when dialogue is
possible when it's not but when you have
two political movements or political
cultures
that can come to some kind of truce or
some kind of
parody or some kind of sense of well i'm
not going to go on the attack right now
because
i'll get it just as bad then you create
the possibility of a kind of
a battlefield turns into some common
ground uh and i think that's that's
important and frankly the the
progressives are
are still much stronger on this stuff
and the conservatives find themselves oh
you know dude where are my tax cuts
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification
bell and we are also available on all
podcast platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you